presidential candidates crisscrossing
the midwest today holding multiple
rallies in multiple states
at the same time the democratic vice
presidential candidate pushing a get out
the vote effort in a republican
stronghold
skyler henry has more from the white
house
president trump returns to the midwest
with rallies in michigan
wisconsin and minnesota it's cold but i
feel very warm in this group
we win this state you know what it's
over
we win wisconsin 2020 democratic
presidential candidate joe biden
is also stumping in minnesota and
wisconsin but first he went to iowa
your values are baked in their iowa
values their american values
you value honor decency respect
and dignity you know they all matter the
democrats are making a
big push friday in texas a state that
hasn't turned blue in a presidential
election in 44 years
democratic vice presidential candidate
kamala harris is in the lone star state
for multiple campaign events
you have power and at election time that
power will be
through your vote early voter turnout in
texas has
already exceeded the entire turnout in
2016
and the latest cbs news battleground
tracker poll shows the two candidates
running neck and neck
texas who are doing very well the vice
president is
also in the southwest in nearby arizona
we need
arizona to show america
that this is trump country the country
is still
four days away from choosing the next
president but inauguration preparations
are
already underway on capitol hill where
the platform is under construction
the election winner will be sworn in
there in less than three months
skyler henry cbs news the white house
and of course the campaigning continues
this weekend tomorrow former president
barack obama expected to join his former
vice
president joe biden for driving rallies
in flint and detroit michigan
while president trump will barnes storm
across the key battleground state of
pennsylvania
tuesday will be a tremendous day for our
country and our state and we'll be with
you all the way our coverage on 8 news
now starts at 4 pm
and together with cbs news we'll be on
all night bringing you up to the minute
numbers as soon as they come in
you'll get all the numbers from the
local level to the race for president on
air and online at 8newsnow.com